il ya tourné ça avec une vieille caméra
16 mm dans cette salle de l'université
du québec à montréal se trouve peut-être
le futur denys arcand
six étudiants suivent le baccalauréat en
communication création médias cinéma on
forme des cinéastes ont formé les gens
qui vont pratiquer le cinéma comme tel
on n'est pas vraiment un baccalauréat
depuis où on va former des théoriciens
on invite les gens à réfléchir à leurs
pratiques a développé des méthodes pour
écrire pour penser pour produire pour
réaliser pour monter le cinéma juste la
suite dans son le programme est très
content ingénieurs en moyenne seulement
trente étudiants sont acceptées par
promotion sur 350 demandes ils vont
devenir réalisateur directeur photo ou
monteur une autre des particularités
qu'on a c'est que je pense la plupart
des gens qui enseignent intérieur du
programme ce sont des gens qui viennent
du milieu professionnel et sait déjà
qu'ils ont souvent garder un pied dans
la pratique est donc sûr ça aide
beaucoup aussi pour maintenir des liens
avec le milieu avec l'industrie
geneviève perron ex diplômés et
directrice photo renommée il donne par
exemple des cours de direction photo
c'est très perméable entre le milieu et
et la formation
moi quand je tourne j'amène les
étudiants sur mes plateaux il rencontre
des gens ils voient comment ça se passe
donc vraiment un lien très étroit entre
la formation et le monde du cinéma
je pensais la spécificité du programme
c'est vraiment qu'on est axée sur les
projets sur la production les
les étudiants tourne énormément de
projets en étant ici de grands noms du
cinéma d'ici sont diplômés de cette
école le plus connu de nili neuf mais
aussi léa pool
jean claude lauzon louis bélanger et
rémy saint michel qui présentait
mercredi son premier long métrage au
rendez vous du cinéma québécois
j'ai axé sur la pratique s'est axée sur
deux de peaufiner notre création puis
non
notre technique aussi des résultats le
plus près possible de des films qu'on
convoi professionnellement on sait
qu'actuellement sur nos bas il y en ad
vraiment d excellence et qu'on sait
qu'ils vont mettre le pied à l'étrier
dans quelques années qui vont prendre la
relève
une pépinière de talents donc qui n'a
pas fini de former ceux et celles qui
feront le cinéma québécois dès demain
[Musique]